if you were going to teach your own
impromptu film class
what five movies would you require the
students to watch
oh wow okay um
the five movies i would have them watch
the first one i already mentioned it uh
sam sarah um
just the most pure perfect form of
filmmaking
uh that film i saw it four times in the
theater made me cry every time at the
end
it is one of those powerful films i've
ever seen and there's not a word of
dialogue
or narration it's literally images music
and profound storytelling so that one
just as an experiment in like this is
the purest form of cinema there is
uh at least in my perspective um
the other one steve mcqueen's hunger um
remember walking out of hunger being
both mind blown and depressed because i
realize i'll never make a film nearly
that good
but mcqueen's ability to make the most
visceral
exhausting brutal movie that
is composed of long takes and almost no
speaking
uh is just breathtaking again just pure
perfect
cinema so definitely those two
then it would be uh dr strangelove
uh for that one
is just how like the perfect political
satire the perfect film for you know you
take a director like kubrick is so known
for
heavy heavy films with very like nuanced
performances and just to go over the top
and
to be able to dissect them i could talk
about that one for a long time but just
how that film
has all the trademark rubric things but
done in such a different way
and to really understand comedy if you
don't know comedy your films are gonna
be boring
um understand how comedy works i think
is so essential to filmmaking
uh you know i if i had one regret about
freights i didn't have enough
levity in it uh so definitely that one
um god what would it be uh
so that's three yeah i think um
oh uh
i would have to go like way back to um
to see uh force of nature
uh forget even the director's name but i
only found out about it because
scorsese said an interview was one of
his favorite films like well i gotta
check it out
it's a film noir um
it's such a it's a you know because it's
older it's a little bit simpler it's not
relying on like extreme production value
or whatever
pacing dialogue performance all the plot
points is one of the most efficient
enjoyable films i've ever seen so that
one just for like efficient smart
storytelling it's so good
and then oh god
um probably honestly like
a jj abrams movie just because the guy
like if you want to make money
learn from the master this guy does pop
culture movies better than anybody
you know him or spielberg one of those
two where it's like you know take one of
their big hits and like
never forget to entertain your audience
either i think is like a key part of
filmmaking is
you know you can learn all the artistry
all the craft have all the heady stuff
in there
but don't forget people paid money or
gave you time of their life
and let them enjoy it too so
that'd be my my course that'd be your
course okay
and what would be the hardest curriculum
i mean sorry what would you
say what would be the hardest uh part of
the curriculum
what would be the one like sort of like
tough love uh
part of the class that uh maybe the
students would block at but you feel
like they would need to know
um i don't know i think like
my own regret actually i used to do i
used to do
talks at different film schools and i
always would tell people
the one thing that and you'll hate to
hear this because i didn't listen to it
when i was younger and the only way i
ever learned this
was tripping and falling flat on my face
a hundred times
running into walls trying to look for an
exit on a doorway to the next
step learn how to start up
a business if every film you do
is a business startup and if you don't
know how to properly start up a business
you are going to lose your ass for my
language
you're gonna you're going to you know
it's unless you unless you're fortunate
enough to have
you know a proper investors and a
producer an executive producer and all
those people that are managing that for
you if you're doing like
bootstraps like making your own film
your way with whatever proceeds you
could
wrangle up you're making you're
starting up your own business approach
it as one no matter how low your budget
is
have a strat have a startup strategy
have a marketing strategy have all that
from the moment that you're like oh this
is the script i'm going to make
from that moment on start treating it
like a business as well because
if you don't you're going to make a lot
of lot of dumb mistakes that i've made a
hundred times and
learned the hard way so i would honestly
if i was truly teaching a filmmaking
course i would have a whole
section on business startups and and you
know what do they say ninety percent of
startups fail
so let filmmakers know that you know um
most films fail go into that knowing it
uh if you're not willing to accept
failure then you'll never make something
original because you're going to be
constantly trying to make something
that's going to please people which
means it's going to be based on what
already exists
and if you're not willing to go out on a
limb
then you're not going to succeed so you
got to be willing to accept there's a
good chance i'm going to fail
you know i was saying it earlier fray i
expected nobody was going to watch it
um and i got lucky people did
with this one i hope people want to
watch it but there's a part of me that's
really braced forward to just
tank i have no idea and i
would never want to go into a film
expecting it to be a success because
then you're just setting yourself up for
disappointment
so that would be that'd be my thing is
accept failure learn from it and know
that failure is what leads to
originality
um and then learn business
you